[Music]
aaron donald of the la rams came in
number one on the latest list of the top
100 players in the national football
league as voted on by the players some
of the great players in the nfl don't
play quarterback we get so caught up in
the quarterback concept but a ton of
special players who make a real
difference for their teams so
with the appropriate disclaimer that we
are not attempting or intending to apply
the jinx to anyone
today's draft the
non-quarterback injury that would most
likely derail the team's season again
we are not jinxing anyone and i know
that it doesn't matter if i say that if
one of these guys ends up tearing an acl
during the preseason but the question is
this is a a an intellectual exercise
which non-quarterback injury would
completely screw things up for the team
chris go ahead and win the coin toss and
you can make the first pick we'll go
heads we'll go heads i think she's going
ahead she's gonna try to give it to you
today yep i knew it i'm on a roll three
for four my first week i'm back baby
yeah yeah
dominating the coin toss i'll let you
call the coin toss next week so i don't
keep dominating you there uh all right
go ahead who do you have i'm gonna go
with aaron donald i mean i'm i'm going
with aaron donald yes i mean hey i don't
think the rams are gonna like fall off
the cliff
okay if aaron donald got hurt and wasn't
playing but man it would change their
whole football team a whole lot i mean
i'm not sure you know that defense again
you know aaron donald makes everybody
better there uh the front four they're
all better players because aaron donald
i mean you saw my interview with aaron
rodgers i mean the whole game plan he
talked about that week was where's aaron
donald we got to slide to him we got to
insert we got to change the protection
we got to do all these different things
he's the greatest interior pass rusher
we've ever seen
he's a first ballot hall of famer and
yes you know me mike the havoc a lot of
the havoc he causes with you know my f
the play up stat right i mean he's his
stats are phenomenal but it's even
better than a stat so that's the one i
look at and just go man that would
really be bad for a team if they lost
aaron donald
you know you very easily could adapt
your oh aaron rodgers song to oh aaron
donald you're right you're right it's
just the same tune right oh aaron
[Music]
that means i'm going to continue to hear
that well beyond the retirement of aaron
rodgers as long as anyone named aaron is
playing in the nfl at a high level and
there's two syllables in his last name
we're gonna continue to hear that tune
uh i agree with you i think that's the
obvious first choices in one of those
days where it really does benefit you to
win the rig coin toss however however
i've got a guy who plays for a team with
far lower expectations than the rams but
if this guy would get injured the season
would be done it already may be done but
it will be even more done if saquon
barkley greatest offensive weapon in the
nfl were to go down because i think the
giants finally realized because i
remember when the vikings understood
what they had in adrian peterson in 2007
they immediately
tore up the playbook and refocused every
game plan through adrian peterson and i
feel like the giants finally got around
to it late in the year but going into
this year i think the plan is saquon
barkley to set up everything else or
anything else that we can do
and if he would go down and i think he
i don't want to make the jinx worse by
saying he just seems indestructible but
if he if he's gone if you take him out
of the mix the giants are 2 and 14. i
mean mike
i'm so mad i mean i i didn't take him
number one because i was hoping you
might go with somebody else on another
higher profile team or a team with
higher expertise this really is the
number one pick okay this is the i mean
you talk about because like we said like
i kind of said with my disclaimer with
aaron donald i don't think the rams
would like fall off earth i think the
giants fall off earth if saquon barkley
gets hurt like i'm not sure they can win
a freaking football game it could get
like that like especially now in lieu of
the wide receiver injuries and all that
so i'm with you i mean come on all we
talk about why didn't you take him there
because i was saying why are you saying
these things out
honest i was trying to sandbag you i
didn't think you'd take them number one
i thought maybe i could get aaron donald
and saquon one too so that really hurt
me big time there okay i'm gonna go with
you're on the ropes baby i'm i'm giving
you those rocky balboa you know the deep
punches lifting up apollo creed off the
mat who you got yeah well i like i like
that pick i my my own creativity came
back to kick me in the butt there i'm
down to two guys here and okay the guy
i'm gonna go with right now
man okay i'm going with deandre hopkins
houston texans okay because who else is
there who i mean it's desean watson and
deandre hopkins i know lamar miller his
talented running back but that offensive
lines had issues i don't know what
they're gonna be will fuller we've
talked about it a few times this week
he's coming off the acl injury again
there's nobody else there in that
houston texans team to be worried about
on the offensive side of the ball
especially in the pass game it's a very
underwhelming group there in houston
very unproven i don't know what to think
of it and so much of the offense goes
through deandre hopkins as is already
let alone i think that would only
increase or stay the same this year
because of all the things we're saying
so man i think the the houston texans
fall off earth if they don't have
deandre hopkins
hey who's the better quarterback dak
prescott or deshaun watson deshawn
watson
okay thank you for helping make my case
my pick is ezekiel elliott he is the
straw that stirs the drink we're so
caught up in him not being there by way
of his holdout we're not thinking hey
when he shows up he could have the jamal
anderson torn acl week one remember that
jamal anderson held out after that 1998
season dan reeves was the coach jamal
anderson finally shows up tears his acl
early on in the year and dan reeve said
well that's what happens when you hold
out look again i'm very nervous about
potentially creating a jinx scenario but
if you take ezekiel outlet out of the
mix for the entire year with the dallas
cowboys
i the the texans are better off with
deshawn watson running the show without
deandre hopkins than the cowboys would
be with dak prescott trying to run the
show without ezekiel elliott there to
set things up although i think prescott
would do better than we would expect
yeah i still think that losing ezekiel
for the year would derail this potential
super bowl run that the cowboys are
plotting and that's why elliot's holding
out yeah because he's applying leverage
to a team that believes it's got a super
bowl roster no it's a good one i i like
my deandre hopkins pick better than that
but i still i like your say i mean your
uh ezekiel elliott i really do only
thing i guess i give the the just a
little
glimmer of hope to a degree is yeah they
got a stable running backs their
offensive lines still good and their
defense is good the team is really good
around them but you know i'm just trying
to make a case so i sound better and you
don't sound as good here's the real
question you said before picking hopkins
you had two names left did i just take
your other one and you're now gonna have
to scramble no you know what in all
transparency here okay i forgot to write
ezekiel elliott's name down okay i'm not
even gonna lie i got like nine games i
got nine names down here and i did not
like write ezekiel elliot because i
think it was so obvious and we've talked
about him so much the last few days that
i've gone uh i i just blanked out on it
like an idiot so okay
gu gosh i don't know where i want to go
here i don't want to throw my names out
because i know you got one more pick but
i'm going to go alvin kamara with the
new orleans saints i think that could
derail their season i mean one mark
ingram's not there two can we trust
latavius murray i mean latavius murray
hasn't quite been
you know what what we want him to be
since he left the the oakland raiders
that worries me but i mean as we saw in
the nfc championship game i mean alvin
kamara such a weapon for this offense
and sean payton and all the things he
does for it not only is it phenomenal
runner and they're a running football
team at this point the new orleans
saints they want to run first but like
we saw in the nfc championship all the
ways they can use them in the short
passing game that's where sean payton's
amazing i mean he might be the greatest
ever at finding five yard completions
and alvin kamara fits into that scheme
and that role so well that man i think
this offense would really uh you know
really have to take a step back and
totally redirect its strengths and how
it's going to attack teams if it didn't
have alvin kamara
hey do me a favor yeah um
rank the quarterbacks in the nfc south
for me
well i mean you know my rankings in the
nfc south i mean what do i got i go matt
ryan cam newton
um drew brees and then jameis winston
wait a minute brees was number nine in
your quarterback list wasn't he yeah is
he 10 no is he cam newton no he's behind
cam newton he was behind cam newton yes
behind matt ryan and and kim newton yes
he was
do the panthers have more offensive
weapons or fewer offensive weapons than
the city i know you're thinking of
christian mccaffrey i know he's i'm just
trying i'm trying to set you up
i think i think christian mccaffrey is
more dispensable to the panthers than
alvin kamara is to the saints and i
think christian mccaffrey for some
reason is ridiculously underrated and
i've tipped here's what i did in our
last segment on
on tv only right i said the three guys
who are the running backs who are
special right and they are saquon
barkley ezekiel elliott and christian
mccaffrey and with all the stuff that
cam newton's going through with his
shoulder right i you take christian
mccaffrey out of the mix and the
panthers are
done mccaffrey almost had two well he
did have did he get to 2000 no he got to
to 1900 and change he almost went 1000
1000 rushing and receiving yeah there's
only two guys in league history that
have ever done that he would have roger
yeah well and you well without can
without christian mccaffrey the panthers
are not doing jack squad i think he's
going to have a special year i hope he
stays healthy i hope all these guys that
i've jinxed stay healthy because i think
they are the three truly special and
only three truly special running backs
in the nfl right now well i mean they
they are i think alvin kamara is
probably in that conversation too um but
but either way you know the funny thing
here is you know
we talk about running backs not being
that important and here we have six
picks and we have four running backs
drafted so especially here's the but
here's the thing yeah special running
backs are important yes and and that's
why
we're playing his hand yeah yeah right
did any of us did any of you was melvin
gordon on your list of nine guys deep i
got six names he wasn't on my list no i
got guys like fletcher cox that came up
next i did have christian mccaffrey von
miller i had him on my list chris jones
for the kansas city chiefs i put him on
there as well actually
that's a sneaky good pick yeah that's a
sneaky i had khalil mack as well and you
know what i hey look i put todd gurley
on my list just because yeah they're
putting all those eggs back in that
basket if he isn't available all year
long what the hell are they going to do
right yeah yeah i i hear you i mean todd
gurley is still a huge we don't know
what some of these other running backs
are going to be there with the los
angeles rams and you're right gurley is
special i mean you know again we don't
know where he's at but we know when he's
close to 100 percent he's one of the
most explosive people in all football
with the ball in his hand all right this
is probably i should probably print off
this this graphic that you can see if
you're watching on nbcsn and frame it
this is the biggest landslide win i've
had in one of these
sims has aaron donald deandre hopkins
alvin kamara i've got saquon barkley
ezekiel elliott christian mccaffrey i
came out of this with the three truly
special running backs in the nfl for the
teams where these guys are indeed the
straw that stirs the drink without them
the drink gets moldy and stagnant and
these teens are done without these three
guys same with my three the hell with
you you're wrong no no you're wrong no
you listen you've already conceded
you've got cute by taking aaron donald
instead of saquon barkley and it all
went downhill for you from there we'll
take a break we'll be right back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports